うまぁ
ウマウマっ！
何くっとんねん！！ｗ
（ﾄﾞｩｸｼ!!）
オルルァァァァァァァァァ！！！
なぜ私が今スーパーカップを食べているのかと
言うと、
さのっち！
はい！！
スーパーカップのフタ！
気にしたことあるか！
フタは・・・、
あの、スーパーカップー のフタあると、 思うんですけど
も！
僕、スーパーカップを食べ続ける事によって
このスーパーカップのふたに
ある可能性を見出してしまいました
このスーパーカップのふた　滅茶苦茶丈夫にできています
まわりのこの金の部分がすごいしっかりできていて
意外とみんなは知らないと思うんですけども
このスーパーカップのふた
投げると
滅茶苦茶飛びます！
知ってた？
ちょっとこの広い場所を使って
このスーパーカップのふたがどれくらい・・・
このスーパーカップのふたがどれだけ飛ぶかを
ちょっとみなさんにお伝えしたいと思います
身近なところに
・・・
用意しといて！
はは！
身近なところに
遊び心あります
ではいこう
信じてないでしょ？
やったことないっすもん
いきます
いくよ？
本当に普通のあれだからね？
ヒュー（飛ぶ効果音）
ちょっと待って
（全っ然飛ばねぇじゃねーかよ）
（新しい世界見せてくれるんじゃなかったのかよ）
やべぇ飛ばねぇとサブチャンネルになる
やばい
参る！
はい
ヒュー（飛ぶ効果音）
（なんだよこのクソ動画）
うわぁ！
ほらほらほらほら
飛ぶやん　飛ぶっちゃ飛ぶよね？
おぉ！
お～お～おぉぉ
（あっやべっクソ飛ばねぇ）
（ラウワン（ラウンドワン）のボーリングの方が100楽しいじゃん）
（ラウワンのボーリングの方が100楽しいじゃん）
うわぁぁ！！
（痛いなクソ野郎が！）
（マジでなめてんじゃねぇぞ）
（あ　ヤベ）
（当たっちゃった）
（ゴメス！）
あ～すごいすごいすごいすごい
え～やばいよ
なんかいい！楽しいっすねこれ
（おうち帰りてぇ）
（いつまで続くんだろうこれ）
（ま！とりま！）
（営業スマイルで！）
（投げときますか！）
ヒュー（飛ぶ効果音）
（でも一応「面白い」って言っておくか）
いや、面白いっすね　はじめさん
そうだよな？
面白いよな？
HAHAHA☆
（絶対思ってねぇ）
え～みなさん
ご覧のとおり
あんまり面白くないです
ふざけんじゃねえ
（ﾄﾞｩｸｼ!!）